[Music]
centerwell senior Primary Care the
sponsors of this next segment want to
remind older adults how important it is
to focus on nutrition as you age because
as you change so should your diet
Dr Wakefield welcome back
oh good to see you Rocky good to see you
too now we're talking about nutritional
changes as we age and Center well is
focused on our seniors in the community
so you know explain how nutritional
needs change as we get older
well it's really interesting because we
often know that as we age we need less
calories so we need less caloric intake
but we also have often have increased
nutritional needs because of various
conditions as we age what kind of foods
should seniors be choosing then in their
diets we want to kind of stay on the
perimeter of the grocery stores and that
includes the dairy the meat and the
produce sections
and what about our seniors who you know
have to rely on packaged Foods you
really want to check the labels and find
those that are lower in salt and fat and
sugar because there are a lot of great
products out there even if they are
processed and packaged you just gotta
read those labels how important is
protein in a seniors diet we know that
patients are people over the age of 71
often don't get enough protein in their
diet and it's really important because
maintaining lean muscle mass as we age
is important to prevent a lot of things
from happening particularly like Falls
and you know kind of those stability
issues so it's important to make sure
that even though you know you're getting
your protein into right you're getting
those lean protein sources so not only
the meat and the uh you know and the
fish and the poultry but you got to
think about those other things like soya
you know the Fortified soy or also beans
and legumes that you know other people
may see you know maybe seeking out for
additional lean protein sources so it's
really important to follow a healthy
diet that also gives you that lean
protein but also there's also those
other added nutrients that you want to
look for like vitamin D and calcium and
vitamin B12 what else does Center will
offer our seniors
so we're really lucky that we have a
real team-based approach and this is
particularly important in this nutrition
that we're speaking about so not only
are you assisted by your doctor but also
with care coaches and you know clinical
Pharmacists and social workers so that
we can make sure that those nutritional
needs that you may need based on you
know some of the
um the conditions that you have are
being addressed through the food that
you get so really we have that you know
the the luxury of the time to get to
know you address those specific
nutritional needs because we also know
that nutrition and health is a very
personal thing so we want to make sure
to help you make those choices in our
centers you know the other thing in our
centers is we're really focused on the
seniors so you'll find that we have you
know non-slip floors we also have white
hallways and doors we have exam tables
that make it easier for you to be
examined so all these things really help
us meet the holistic needs of our
patients not only the physical aspect
effects but also the emotional the
social and the you know financial needs
as well
thank you Center well senior primary
care for sponsoring this segment they
have like 11 locations across the Las
Vegas Valley and for more information
all you got to do is head to
centerwelllasvegas.com